merci par le tas jean lassalle non
inscrits en trois ans c'est bon de morts
pendant la visite et madame le président
madame mariniste
la dame et le sérieux rapporte mesdames
et messieurs les députés chers collègues
c'est bien entendu un sujet de toute
première importance qui nous réunit ce
soir et dire d'abord que tout ce qui
peut contribuer au fait de pousser à
nouveau nos concitoyens aux urnes part
d'un bon sentiment jeu parce que le
disque des dispositions de facilitation
de planification que prévu on a ce sera
donc ce je ne peux que m'en réjouir
je ci étant que me l'ont dit la plupart
des collègues sont exprimés sur le sujet
je crois que le problème est hélas
beaucoup plus profond le savons tous je
pense qu'il est aussi dû à un changement
demande quel nos assistants je ne cesse
de le répéter le bim trentaine d'années
changement demande comme il y en a eu
d'autres sur notre ère chaque fois
d'ailleurs que le monde a bougé on
magellan et ses copains ont retrouvé les
haines les amériques sa bouleverser
totalement les royaumes de l'époque
parce que bien sûr l'argent la
spéculation a pris le pouvoir
lorsqu'elle aurait dû xxème siècle les
mêmes se sont rendus compte que c'est
rennes qui s'étiraient à perte de vue
jusqu'au fond d amérique d europe si
étrange volatile en acier
et que là se pète liquide de couleur
indéfinissable était certainement de
ceux de toutes les sous couches du sol
et même en pensée il n'y aurait jamais
eu autant de profits à faire que les
luttes de pouvoir allait atteindre un
niveau jamais atteint dans l'histoire
ils sont pas trompés s'adonner les deux
tragédies du 21e siècle nous sommes sont
maintenant d'un troisième mouvement de
mondialisation avec notamment internet
jamais autant d'informations ont été
portés à notre connaissance et jamais il
n'a été aussi difficile de dire où un
jour son voisin je crois que c'est cela
ces éléments la touche à l'humain
aujourd'hui auxquels nos concitoyens
attendent des réponses est la moins que
l'on puisse se dire c'est que je ne
trouve pas ni les heures ni les autres
très inspiré ça viendra j'espère je
souhaite de tout coeur en tant qu'axe ne
viennent pas trop tard tous les éléments
de quelque côté que l'on appréhende le
globe
notre france chérie le montrent il est
déjà très tard je vois que sur les
élections régionales vont une fois de
plus battre les records l'abstention
même et en dépit je le regrette
le ministre une pour y ait des facilités
vous apporter mais tout simplement parce
que nos compatriotes n'ont pas envie de
voter à faire à moins que je rencontre
vraiment ceux qui sont les plus
récalcitrants mais il n'ya plus c'était
là n'a plus envie alors je le dis
malgré tout la sympathique je porte aux
députés et à l'homme je suis en
désaccord total 1 françois de rugy et 6
mai
cette maison est faite pour exprimer
aussi des désaccords pour moi
la vote obligatoire ce serait le niveau
zéro de la démocratie si on m'impose est
à moi le fait d'aller voter et bien
tellement accroché à l'expression du
vote au suffrage universel que je n'irai
pas voyez alors je suis certain nombre
en tout cas extrême mais il pourrait
s'en trouver quelque chose pour moi
non simplement faisons en sorte de
trouver des débats plus voilà plus
porteur soit plus porteurs d'idées
nouvelles que celui que nous avons su
par exemple cet après midi aux à propos
de très grands sujets celui de la grèce
et qui à mon avis n'est pas la hauteur
de l'assemblée nationale n'est pas
obligé de préciser française parce que
tout le monde sait que l'assemblée
nationale et france elle souvent
d'autres moyens alors ils sont bien sûr
difficile mais c'est pareil non je n'ai
pas dépassé quelques nominations clefs
merci aux clients de conclure lanctôt
vendre d'autres moyens tout simplement
de faire le travail du politique
le politique c'est un rêve politique
c'est une utopie
le politique c'est de passer la cité de
lui donner un futur un lendemain et de
le faire avec le peuple lillois
aujourd'hui est perdue de vue
j'en appelle au retour du citoyen il
reviendra espérons qu'ils ne reviennent
pas trop tard